У вівторок і середу вранці псевдовбивство Аркадія Бабченка
стало темою номер один у всіх німецьких ЗМІ.
Європейські та німецькі політики,
зокрема і президент Німеччини Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр,
який перебував у той час із робочим візитом в Україні,
висловили потрясіння і стурбованість тим, що сталося,
а також закликали обидві сторони - Київ і Москву -
негайно провести розслідування і притягнути винних до відповідальності.
Представник ОБСЄ з питань свободи ЗМІ Арлем Дезір
спеціально відправився до Києва, щоб висловити співчуття близьким Бабченка
і з'ясувати обставини його загибелі.
Але вже після прибуття до Києва представник ОБСЄ
дізнався про інсценування, розігране спецслужбами України.
Реакція Арлема Дезіра на "воскресіння" Бабченка
вельми показова. Подібним чином відреагували
практично всі оглядачі, політики та правозахисники на Заході.
Пояснити і виправдати фейкове вбивство Бабченка
буде для України дуже непросто.
На даний момент створюється відчуття,
що Київ спробував зіграти на емоціях, обравши цей
безпрецедентний шлях. У Німеччині багато оглядачів
навіть задаються запитанням, наскільки взагалі ще можна довіряти
українським політикам та уряду.
Коли справа дійшла до конфронтації між Москвою і Києвом у 2014 році
і почалася війна на Сході України, то
багато в чому це була війна пропаганди,
взаємних звинувачень і фейкових новин.
Тоді здавалося, що гору в такій війні бере Росія
з її масованою держпропагандою і використанням
державних ЗМІ проти України. Україна ж весь час
заявляла, що знаходиться на боці правди і захищає
західні цінності. Тепер це виявилося під питанням.
Я не можу зрозуміти, навіщо українські спецслужби це зробили.
Навіть якщо і стало відомо про існування планів
вбивства пана Бабченка, спецслужби повинні використовувати
інші способи запобігання замаху,
не вдаючись до інсценування вбивства.
Цей випадок вчергове продемонстрував те, що
дезінформацію все частіше застосовують як зброю,
що політиків і ЗМІ не можна використовувати як інструменти з подібними цілями.
Я впевнений, що Захід продовжить надавати Україні
підтримку при проведенні демократичних та економічних реформ
і не змінить своєї позиції щодо Криму та війни на Сході України.
В цьому немає жодних сумнівів.
Але в майбутньому на Заході будуть більш обережними з тим,
яку оцінку давати тим чи іншим подіям.
Адже раніше мали місце вбивства критично налаштованих
щодо Кремля журналістів. Але тепер подібна інформація
буде ретельно перевірятися, щоб уникнути
подібних маніпуляцій в майбутньому.
Перед відльотом до Києва у четвер
на новину про спецоперацію СБУ відреагував і очільник МЗС Німеччини Гайко Маас.
Яким би химерним цей випадок не здавався,
те, що в цьому регіоні - і не тільки там, -
журналісти, як і раніше, стають жертвами насильства і вбивств,
на жаль, не розіграш і не курйоз, а гірка правда.